[Music]
early in the morning millions of people
here at Germany drag themselves out of
bed and head off to work many of them
would prefer to stay in bed a little
longer huntersville i got up at
seven-thirty i said 545 was at six well
this I do love to sleep in yeah yeah no
I'm still really tired it's not for me i
like i sleep till nine bettina headache
a journalist from hamburg says we live
in a dictatorship of the early risers
she says she's insufferable before 10am
but she's put plenty of long nights into
writing her book on the benefits of a
good lie in the morning man Canadian
mention exempted gone soon it's an
intolerable imposition on humanity to
make us continue living under such
conditions you have to live against your
biorhythm you poorly rested your
unconsecrated you're in a bad mood
Mensch you're an example of precisely
the type of person called a morning
grouch antigua ah but in reality those
are the night owls very creative
individuals even mentioned
there are plenty of prominent examples
the tenor luciano pavarotti was a
professed late riser as are the brothers
bill and tom Kaulitz of the german pop
band tokio hotel so was Albert Einstein
actress Marilyn Monroe cultivated her
beauty sleep until midday and science
supports and X thesis Peter quince of
Berlin as a renowned German sleep
researcher research shows that late
risers can't be any other way its
genetic one says that he too likes to
start the day a little later than many
people yet sitepoint monata this license
my most productive time is set by a
system of internal clocks when da man
the late sleeper type baked tends to be
at his or her best in the evening said
license fees guy time adesh been
achieved and i will late sleeper sleeps
best between 3 and 11 in the morning
damn wassup if he has to get up during
the workweek five six or seven it
violates his biorhythm the same way as
when someone else flies to New York or
Tokyo not New York otopeni under a stone
not Tokyo free half the population feels
like it's jet lagged all the time
because our lives are arranged around
getting up early offices schools and
doctors offices usually open early the
result a society of weary people
yep all gasp linked and Elijah urgently
need a revolution of the late sleepers
because so much economic potential is
wasted this myth that the early risers a
better people that the harder workers is
very widespread their fists cos its but
that myth is slowly crumbling how can
people live and work to suit their own
rhythm more and more companies are
looking for answers the berlin fashion
online magazine seven trends has gone a
step further co-founder sebastian
Ziegler Schmidt is a late riser and he
wanted to build a company in which no
one has to ignore his body clock Malcolm
call me I can cleesh fist Abbott's why
do we need regular working hours every
person is different we all know this
some people are morning people others
are nine people so we came up with the
idea that everyone can come and go when
he wants to concede a common game when I
move that was the plan but the liberal
system soon reached its limits
[Music]
the ina coming some sex behind when
summer comes at six in the morning
wanted to work in a team and has to wait
four hours before the next person comes
that's difficult of course and when
business partners call at nine in the
morning in Germany they expect to reach
someone this year about advertisement
and he-man and fifty but late risers
like Bettina Hennig still question the
traditional system that is comped eating
kinda often gedanken dusts nobody has
the idea that the structures should
change if everyone seems to think that
the people ought to change that they
should just continue get started and
I'll be intimidated by problems
pioneering achievements and start-up
problems alphonse problems taking two
dozen so there's still lots left to do
tomorrow morning Bettina Hennig will
continue her campaign for the rights of
late risers but not before ten o'clock
[Music]